balancear ecuaciones químicas es uno de
esos conceptos que a veces confunde
mucho a la gente pero yo creo que como
veremos en este vídeo si trabajamos este
tema cuidadosa y metódicamente también
vamos a poder apreciar el arte de
balancear ecuaciones y ya no solo nos
vamos a confundir sino que además vamos
a saborear muy bien de qué se trata de
esto de balancear las ecuaciones así que
antes que nada pues nos podríamos
preguntar qué es una ecuación química
para empezar verdad y aquí justamente
tenemos una verdad esta está real este
esto que tenemos aquí representa o
describe una reacción verdad aquí
tenemos un átomo de aluminio que al
juntarse con una molécula de atómica de
oxígeno es decir tenemos dos átomos de
oxígeno en esta misma molécula y bajo
condiciones adecuadas verdad en la que
se puede llevar a cabo esta reacción
pues vamos a obtener un producto verdad
que sería el óxido de aluminio
este óxido de aluminio se caracteriza
por tener dos átomos de aluminio y tres
de oxígeno verdad y tú te estarás
preguntando bueno de qué se trata todo
esto de balancear ecuaciones y tienes
que mirar muy bien vamos a ver
si nosotros nos fijamos por ejemplo en
en la cantidad de átomos de aluminio que
aparecen en esta reacción aquí podemos
observar que hay un átomo de aluminio
digamos del lado de los reactivos verdad
mientras que el número de átomos de
aluminio que hay en los productos en el
producto más bien serían dos verdad
entonces uno se preguntaría bueno cómo
es que a partir de un átomo de aluminio
obtenemos dos no es como que salga del
oxígeno verdad o sale a lo mejor de la
nada o de forma espontánea aquí no hay
nada de magia lo que pasa es que no está
bien balanceada la ecuación verdad lo
mismo podríamos observar por ejemplo
para el oxígeno verdad con el oxígeno
aquí tenemos dos átomos de oxígeno
mientras que del lado de los del
producto más bien tenemos tres átomos de
oxígeno entonces nuevamente parece como
que el oxígeno salió de la nada y no es
eso sino que nos hace falta balancear
está ecuación es decir que haya tantos
átomos de aluminio del lado izquierdo
como del
derecho y lo mismo para el oxígeno
verdad entonces una forma en que
podríamos ir intentando hacer esto sería
por ejemplo poner que del lado de los
reactivos necesitaremos 2 2 a todos
moléculas mono atómicas de aluminio
verdad entonces aquí ya no tendríamos un
aluminio sino tendríamos 2 y ahí ya
quedan balanceados el número de
aluminios que hay en esta reacción
verdad ahora también podríamos pensar
que necesitamos un poco más de una de
estas moléculas para tener para poder
alcanzar 33 átomos de oxígeno verdad que
es lo que tenemos del lado derecho
entonces nosotros podríamos por ejemplo
multiplicar por 1.5 verdad 1.5 por 2 ya
serían 3 y lo cual nos dice que ya está
balanceada la ecuación ahora aquí
implícitamente estamos diciendo que hay
un átomo perdón una una molécula de
óxido de aluminio verdad entonces ahí
tendríamos balanceada la ecuación son
por lo general no nos gusta poner
números digamos
que no sean enteros verdad aquí el 1.5
no es entero y no nos gusta porque al
menos no tenemos la la noción de por
ejemplo media molécula verdad o una
molécula y media entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es reescribir esta reacción
pero en donde podamos obtener números
enteros como digamos coeficientes
digamos ok entonces vamos a poner
nuestro aluminio que se junta con el
oxígeno y que nos produce óxido de
aluminio muy bien y entonces lo que
vamos a hacer y esto se relaciona un
poquito con las ecuaciones algebraicas
que hemos visto en matemáticas es vamos
a buscar un número un número que al
multiplicarlo por 1.5 nos dé un número
entero y que sea lo más pequeño posible
entonces vamos a multiplicar toda la
reacción por ese número entonces por
ejemplo si nosotros multiplicamos por 2
el 1.5 que tendríamos
y nosotros tendríamos que 2 por 1.5 nos
da 3 verdad entonces si multiplicamos
toda la reacción por 2 aquí tendríamos 4
verdad serían 4 átomos de aluminio
verdad tendríamos 4 átomos de aluminio y
si multiplicamos por 2 el 1.5 tendríamos
3 moléculas de co2 verdad tenemos 3
moléculas de o2 por otro lado del lado
de los del producto tendríamos dos
moléculas de óxido de aluminio y ahora
sólo tenemos que verificar que en efecto
siguen estando balanceados aquí por
ejemplo en aluminio tenemos cuatro
átomos mientras que del lado derecho
también tenemos cuatro átomos verdad
entonces está bien balanceado el
aluminio y del lado izquierdo del
oxígenos tenemos seis átomos de oxígeno
verdad porque tenemos tres moléculas que
tienen dos átomos de oxígeno eso nos da
y del lado derecho tenemos al revés dos
moléculas de esta que tiene tres átomos
de oxígeno entonces eso nos da seis y
por lo tanto ya tenemos nuestra ecuación
balanceada